what we at the Planetary Society do is
it do our best to advance space science
and exploration we strongly believe that
the search for life is worthy because it
would change the world so as what the to
logical places to look in the solar
system are Mars and this moon of Jupiter
called Europa and if you've never seen
Europa I encourage you to go out there
and take a look you need a telescope or
binoculars and look at Jupiter Jupiter's
a very bright object go to planetary org
we'll show you where it is and you can
see that they look like pinpricks of
light the same pinpricks of light that
Galileo himself observed when he took
what was nominally a military instrument
a telescope for looking at the other
team your enemy on the other hilltop and
pointed it at the sky not only did he
pointed at the sky he pointed at the sky
at night and so he found Jupiter and he
found these four moons which we nowadays
call the Galilean moons after him but
meanwhile dozens of other moons have
been done dozens and the reason we talk
about Europa so often and so much in my
little space community is because it has
twice as much sea water as the earth for
years people who had looked at Europa
did not think it was so good or well
advised to plan a mission there because
the great expense you would have to have
a lander then you'd have some kind have
some kind of amazing drill to drill
through pick a number 20 or 50
kilometres of ice to get to this sea
water and so the surface of Europa is
frozen it's a crust of ice water ice but
below it is liquid water and it's kept
liquid by the gravitational or what we
call tidal action of Europa's orbit with
this massive Jupiter Europa's orbital
period is 85 hours and I got to tell you
I mean imagine the moon going around the
earth every two days every three days
instead of a month you'd have a three
day period it would be really short a
short month and so if this keeps like
squeezing a rubber ball
keeps your opal warm so there's seawater
so it's people who have looked at what
it takes to be a living thing which
nowadays these people nowadays call
themselves we like to call ourselves
itself astrobiology and astrobiologists
have thought deeply about what it takes
to be a living thing you've got to have
a membrane or a wall something that
separates you from what's not you and
you probably have to have a liquid a
solvent and the best solvent anybody can
come up with is water so with the
gravitational action and the frozen icy
crust Europa shoots geysers of water out
into space all the time so now it will
be possible instead of landing there and
building some exotic drill and declaring
the whole mission way too expensive to
ever do you would build a much more
modest spacecraft that would have to go
the extraordinary distance out to
Jupiter and get an orbit out there
around Europa but you would have it fly
through the geysers actually the orbit
be around Jupiter have it fly through
the geysers and like looking at bugs on
the windshield I mean it would be
extraordinary if there are living things
there it would be a great it would be a
worthy thing we may discover life now
John Culberson congressman from Texas
from West Houston believes he's sure of
it he's got to be life on Europa because
it has all these wonderful literally
elements of life the chemicals that make
up life are mixed in the seawater this
has been determined using magnetometers
and spectrometers on the Galileo
spacecraft which has been in orbit out
there for a long time but Europa has sea
water squirting it into space we could
send a relatively inexpensive mission
and that's a relatively inexpensive as
two billion dollars but two billion
dollars spread over ten years
is barely the cup of coffee per taxpayer
once and that pays for the whole mission
over ten years and my feeling is people
buy a lot more than one cup
Coffee every ten years so that's why
somebody in authority somebody with
reasonable insight at NASA said we'll
find life in the next 20 years I would
say the next 30 but 20 was great let's
say if we could launch we could get in
the orbit of Jupiter and Europa by 2022
you'd get results back by 2025 and then
things don't happen as fast as you think
they would so add 10 years yeah so 20
years 20 years from 2014 that's possible
it would change the world for a price of
a cup of coffee and wait there's more it
wouldn't be the work of a guy like
Galileo or Copernicus or Kepler these
are famous names in astronomy or Isaac
Newton or Einstein it would be the work
of all of us it would be the work of all
of us taxpayers and citizens of the
earth who participate in this now it
might be US taxpayers nominally but
guarantee of the European Space Agency
Canadian Space Agency almost certainly
the Indian Space Research Organisation
the Ross cosmos the earth everybody
would have a small part on this mission
everybody would be involved and if we
were to find evidence of life it would
change the world
you